In this video, we'll take a look at Lightmaps and their UVs.
If you don't plan on using Lumen in your project, then you'll probably still want
to keep it optimized by baking your lighting.
You can of course combine baked lighting with Lumen Reflections, but let's assume for a
moment that we are working again for a platform that needs to be hyper-optimized, doesn't
support Lumen or Nanite, again something like a mobile phone.
Lightmaps are a very cheap way to store complex direct and indirect lighting information,
and once lighting data has been baked, that light becomes basically free because nothing
needs to be processed at runtime from it.
Lightmap UVs are different from your texture UVs because a lightmap must have distinct,
separate UVs for every surface of an object even if a texture were to repeat because
shadows might come and hit an object from different angles even if the texture is the
same at those different angles.
You can generate UVs of an Unreal or set them up in your DCC tool.
A Lightmap Index in Unreal Engine by default will be set to Index 0, but that can also
be changed at a later time.
All Lightmap UVs have to fit in the 0-1 UV space with no overlap, otherwise you'll get
some very funky looking light baked data.
Over in our Lightmaps map, we see we have shadows coming off of these two dumpsters.
I'm also going to hold down L and bring in a simple light right here.
We'll give it a color to help it stand out more.
Why not?
Hot pink.
And if I go ahead and do a quick build of my scene, ignoring plenty of other things I
should be doing like a Lightmass Importance Volume, etc., etc.
We can see that Static Mesh Dump Lightmass No has a very high overlapping issue with
its UVs, and this can of course cause problems where we can see on the left dumpster, which
is Lightmass Yes, we have the pink light showing up correctly there, whereas on the Lightmass
No one, things are a little bit broken and wonky.
This should clearly be illuminated, but it's not.
If I jiggle my light here a little bit, you'll see it come back on, and that's from poorly
constructed UVs.
We can see issues over here as well.
This one is fine, but let's go ahead and see if we can fix this one too.
So we'll open up Lightmass No.
We'll find in our details, Lightmap UVs.
We can tell it to generate some Lightmap UVs, but before we do that, let's look at what
we have here.
So yes, this will cause some issues.
We do generate Lightmap UVs and we hit Apply.
We'll now see we have UV Channel 0 and UV Channel 1.
And now if we go ahead and rebuild our lighting, we'll see we actually still have some light.
We'll have the same problem, and that's because of where the Lightmap is currently set up.
So I did say earlier that Lightmaps are typically going to be on Channel 0, but because we generated
the Lightmaps after, it became Channel 1.
Generally the Lightmap is going to be the one with more visible geometry because it's
covering more surface area.
So all we need to do is change our Lightmap Coordinate Index from the default of 0 over
to 1.
Now, it should work.
Let's give it a try.
And there we are.
Pink Light on both sides, as well as our little shadows on the ground.
This is also baking lighting, and if we wanted this to be sharper, we could even change the
Lightmap Resolution of the ground.
Bring it up from 128 to 256 or even 512.
Also note that in order to bake the lighting successfully here, I had to create a Post-Process
Volume and Disable Lumen from Global Illumination.
Otherwise, Lumen will override everything in the scene.
In the next video, we'll explore collisions.